Hello and welcome. I'm James Murphy.
And inthis episode, we're talking about chained comparisons in Python.
By a chained comparison,I mean an expression like this
where I have multiple comparisons.
In this case, I have two lessthans that appear in the same expression.
So, this kind of thing is totally fine in Python.
You canhave as many of these strung together as you want
and you can mix and match operators.
I can useless than, less than or equal to, equals, those kind of things.
And as long as each of the thingspairwise makes sense, like 5 less than equal to 10,
as long as each of these things makes sense, thenthis is a valid thing you can do in Python.
However, what it means is a little bit non-intuitive.
Pythontried to make things work a little bit more like the way that math works.
So, this expression, x < y < z, is supposed to mean what it would in mathematical notation.
Namely that, yis between x and z.
This might be a little bit counter-intuitive especially if you're coming
from a different language,
or if you're trying to comprehend, like:
"Does this happen left to rightand where do the parentheses go?" that kind of thing.
So, if you tried to think about it and you said:Okay, I know y less than z returns a boolean.
So, is this supposed to mean, like
y < z, okay1 is less than 2, that's true,
x is 0. 0 is less than true, that's true?
And you know puttingthe parentheses over here wouldn't really make it any better.
If I did this, you'd still be likecomparing a true and a false versus another thing.
But in Python, they sort of did away with this ideathat
you pick a left to right or right to left way of evaluating the parentheses
and instead theymade it mean following.
Whenever you have something like this,
where you have multiple comparisonoperators in a row,
then you basically just put an and between them.
So, what I had beforeis equivalent to x is less than y and y is less than z.
Doing it this way can save a little bit oftyping, sure.
But one of the main benefits of doing it this way is that
if I have a temporary variablewhere I don't really want to give it a name
if I have something like, you know, I call some functionand I get the return value of the function,
I don't have to now call thisfunction twice.
If I wanted to do it just in the old written out way,
then I wouldhave actually two calls to this function.
And if this function was an expensive function andI didn't want to make two calls
or if it was something that like had side effects and I didn'twant those side effects to happen multiple times,
then I would sort of be forced to make a temporaryvariable storing the value of the function call.
So, allowing these chained comparisons definitely saveson more than just the typing.
It does prevent you from having to do this kind of pattern here.
But the language is actually very very flexible about chaining these comparisons together.
Somuch so that, I think that most of the time you probably shouldn't use this
unless you're justdoing a very simple comparison like x is less than y is less than z.
I think intuitively once youunderstand that this kind of thing is happening,
it's pretty easy to follow and it can make codemore readable even.
But look at all of the things that you could use in a chain comparison.
So, youcan use a less than and greater than, less equal, greater equal,
equals, not equals, is, is not, in andnot in.
All of those things for the purposes of Python are considered comparison operators.
And they can all be chained together.
That means that here I could do something like this
I could say x is less than y is greater than z
Now mathematically, what is this supposed to mean?
I mean, I know Python and I know that the rule is that this means x is less than y and y is greaterthan z.
But looking at it, just looking at x less than y greater than z
that no longer really makessense to me.
It makes way more sense to have the and in the middle there
and to have a temporaryvariable for a function call if I need it.
I don't think it should really even be allowedto mix like less and greater like that in these chained comparisons.
I don't think you're going todo anything but confuse people if you mix a less and a greater and a chained comparison like this.
So,let's just go over some examples of what I think would be good use cases
versus questionable versusjust outright bad.
So, here what I would consider good use cases.
I would argue that in thesecases, it's actually more readable to use the chained comparison
and it agrees with mathematicalnotation and just looking at it it makes sense what it's doing.
It's more readable than whatyou would have if you wrote out the explicit like 0 is less than x and x is less than 1.
So, forthis one, clearly I'm saying x is strictly between 0 and 1. That makes sense.
You can express thingslike closed and open endpoints,
you can express loose inequalities,
you can do things the otherway around,
all of these things just make sense.
It even makes sense to have three things all beingequal to each other.
I think what makes these good cases is that
they're all using sort of the samedirection of comparison operator.
I can still go x is less than or equal to y and y is less than orequal to z.
So, x is less than equal to z. It makes sense to skip from the very left to the very right.
And that's because these comparison operators are transitive.
That's that property. If I have x isless than y and y is less than z, then x is less than z.
So, as long as you're sort of respecting thetransitivity of the operator,
then I don't really have any problem with chaining the comparisons.
Okay, let's look at some more questionable examples.
For these examples, I wouldn't necessarily be upsetif someone tried to submit a pull request
that has something like this to one of my codebases.
But Iprobably wouldn't write something like this myself.
Just because I know that when someone sees, youknow, a big long expression like this,
they're going to have to stop and think, like,
What is evenhappening here?
Like, they're going to have to take a second
to realize that this is a case wherethey need to think about it as a chained comparison.
What this one is saying is that y and z have tobe the same,
x and y are between 0 and 1 with x less than y.
It's definitely cluttered and I wouldconsider refactoring to make it more readable.
But I wouldn't say that it's bad.
In this example,this part is completely fine.
And I think that this example is only questionable because
it's notreally clear how the not equals plays into this.
Is it supposed to be that none of these thingsare equal to one or just that z isn't equal to 1?
Well, since we're saying that they're allequal, it doesn't really make any difference.
So, that's why I would still include this in anokay to questionable use as opposed to a bad use.
So, I think that this example and this example arenot actually that questionable.
I only include them in this questionable use-case scenario
because Ithink that most people probably aren't aware that is and in are considered comparison operators
andcan participate in this chain comparison operation.
If you didn't know that is was allowed toparticipate in comparison,
I would probably just think this is a syntax error.
But once I thinkabout it as a comparison,
then yeah, it makes sense that I'm just saying that x, y and z are allidentical.
They're pointing to the same object.
There's nothing too radical about any of theseexamples
and as long as you have a general awareness that the rule exists,
then you're notgoing to be confused by any of these examples.
However, let's move on to the: Why are these evenallowed examples?
These are really bad use-cases, in my opinion.
I'm actually not sure why this iseven allowed.
If you read the documentation,
it's clear that the person that wrote the documentationknows that this is confusing.
They say something like: Oh yeah, this is allowed.
You're allowed touse mixed, like, less than and greater than or any of the comparison operators.
But it's not prettyis the term that they used.
So, why this is allowed I'm not quite sure.
But it's clear that they knewthat it was a bad idea, basically.
My only guess is that it was due to something about the easeof implementing it in the language
and perhaps due to limitations of the parser.
Here's anotherbad example.
x is not equal to y is not equal to z
Now, if you were to write this in a math paper,
it's probably going to be interpreted that none of these things are equal to each other.
notjust x is not equal to y and y is not equal to z
So, in this case, I think this actually disagreeswith what your intuition might say.
My intuition looking at this says:
This should mean that x, yand z are all distinct.
But it actually doesn't have that implication.
It still could have thepossibility that x and z are equal to each other.
And that's what I think makes this an especiallybad use.
I think any time that you use a not equals as part of a chain comparison,
it's probably goingto confuse people, especially if there are multiple not equals.
And of course, you're allowed to have asmany of these things mixed together as you want.
So, you could write something like this and this isperfectly fine.
Who knows what it means!
I don't even really want to parse it. I just wrote it toshow a bad example.
And here's the motherload of all bad examples that I could come up with.
Leaveyour bad examples in the comments below, by the way.
We're mixing less than and greater than
and we'remixing the right and left bit shift operators.
If anyone knows what this code is supposed to do, goahead tell me.
Now obviously, no one in their right mind is going to write something this terrible
except maybe for an obfuscation contest
where you're supposed to make code look as unreadableas possible.
But I'm just trying to show this as a point where why is this even allowed in thelanguage.
Now, I know Python has a lot of sharp corners. It has a lot of features.
I have a wholevideo on what I think is the sharpest corner of them all,
a sort of a hidden thing that Python doesthat's really unintuitive.
And that's sort of just expected.
Every language is going to have thesethings that are counter-intuitive
or if you don't know the rule,
then it's not really going to makesense to beginners or you know that kind of thing.
But something like this, I just think thatreally shouldn't be part of the language.
Now, I'm not sure how the Python core developerswould feel about
potentially breaking old code that depends on this.
But I think it is agood idea to probably rein in these chained comparisons
and not allow things like lessthan and greater than to be used in the same chained comparison.
So, I'm not saying that we shouldget rid of chained comparisons altogether,
just the ones that inherently don't make sense, like usingless than and greater than together.
On the other hand, I would like to see an expansion of chained comparisons to other cases that do make sense.
So currently, as of today, if you have somethinglike a NumPy array,
it's not currently possible to do something like this.
I can't chain together 3is less than x and x is less than 5.
So, this kind of thing doesn't actually work in Python today.
And I think there is a proposal about a way that it could be made to work.
But that is one directionthat I think that it would be okay if we expanded chained comparisons.
And that's all I've got. Thanksfor watching.
If you liked the video don't forget to like, comment and subscribe.
Special shout outto all my patrons and donors.
Thanks for watching.